♪ ♪
>> RELATES IN NO WAY TO RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, WIKILEAKS,
COLLABORATION, OR ANY OTHER
ILLEGAL ACTION IN CONNECTION
WITH A 2016 CAMPAIGN.
>> IT'S A VERY SERIOUS
INDICTMENT BUT IT SHOWS THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE IS
RECOVERING EVIDENCE IT NEEDS.
>> NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> THIS CONNECTION TO OUR
ELECTION IS OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE TRUTH
ABOUT.
>> WAS THEIR ILLEGAL COLLUSION,
ILLEGAL CONSPIRACY WITH RUSSIA?
WE DON'T FIND IT.
>> Bret: THE SEVEN COUNT
INDICTMENT FOR ROGER STONE AND
IN THAT INDICTMENT, A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PARTS OF IT BUT THIS
SAYS AFTER THE JULY 22ND 2016
RELEASE OF STOLEN DNC EMAILS BY
ORGANIZATION ONE, THAT'S
WIKILEAKS, A SENIOR TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OFFICIAL WAS DIRECTED
TO CONTACT STONE ABOUT AN
ADDITIONAL RELEASE AND OTHER
DAMAGING INFORMATION
ORGANIZATION ONE HAD REGARDING
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN THEREAFTER
TOLD THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN ABOUT
FUTURE RELEASES OF DAMAGING WOOD
MATERIAL BY ORGANIZATION ONE.
THE ACCOUNTS THAT STONE NOW
FACES, FIVE COUNTS OF FALSE
STATEMENTS, ONE COUNT OF WITNESS
TAMPERING AND THERE'S 20 YEARS
IN PRISON OF THAT BASING A
MAXIMUM OF 50 YEARS IN PRISON.
RUDY GIULIANI THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEY SAYING THE INDICTMENT
ISN'T NOTHING MORE THAN ANOTHER
FALSE STATEMENT CHARGE, IT
DOESN'T ALLEGE COLLUSION.
IT CHARGES NO UNDERLYING
WRONGDOING BY MR. STONE OR
ANYONE ELSE, IT SEEMS LIKE WE
ARE COMING TO AN END.
LET'S DIGEST IT WITH OUR PANEL.
BYRON YORK CHIEF POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT OF
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" ," AND
MATTHEW CONTINETTI EDITOR OF
CHIEF OF "THE WASHINGTON
FREE BEACON" ."
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO
RICHARD NIXON AND WATERGATE IS A
TRAGEDY BUT ROGER STONE SEEMS TO
HAVE READ IT AS AN INSTRUCTION
MANUAL IF THE INDICTMENT IS
CORRECT.
NONETHELESS, THE CRIME FOR WHICH
HE WAS INDICTED OUR PROCESS
CRIMES, THEY ARE NOT THE CRIMES
THAT MUELLER WAS APPOINTED TO
INVESTIGATE.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION IS TO
ABLE TO CREATE SOME SPACE
BETWEEN WHAT HAPPENED TO ROGER
STONE AND THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
>> Bret: JOSH?
>> IT DOES FEEL LIKE THE WALLS
ARE CLOSING AND WHEN IT COMES TO
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE AND
POSSIBLE CONNECTIONS TO RUSSIA
AND WIKILEAKS.
STONE IS ONE OF THE MANY
CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS ON THAT TRUMP
CAMPAIGN TO NOW BE INDICTED AND
IT FEELS LIKE THE HEAT IS ON IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
ON THE OTHER HAND FROM THE
POLITICAL POINT OF VIEW IF YOU
REMEMBER BACK IN THE SUMMER OF
2016, TRUMP WAS CALLING PUBLICLY
ON RUSSIA TO RELEASE THE EMAILS
AND A STONE WAS TWEETING ABOUT
THIS FOR EVERYONE WHO FOLLOWS
HIM ON TWITTER TO SEE.
THIS WAS BAKED IN POLITICALLY TO
THE 2016 ELECTION AND I DON'T
THINK THE PUBLIC AND IS
CERTAINLY THE POLITICS OF THIS
CHANGES, UNTIL MUELLER RELEASES
HIS REPORT AND THERE IS EVIDENCE
OF ACTUAL COLLUSION WHICH THERE
HAS NOT BEEN PROVEN TO BE SO
FAR.
THE POLITICS WOULDN'T CHANGE A
WHOLE LOT EVEN THOUGH THIS IS
ANOTHER CONNECTION FROM THAT
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Bret: WE DON'T KNOW THE
SENIOR TRUMP CAMPAIGN OFFICIAL
ORDERED TO TALK TO STONE.
THE WHITE HOUSE AND RUDY
GIULIANI SAYING IT DOESN'T TOUCH
THE PRESIDENT, OBVIOUSLY HE WAS
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
WE DON'T KNOW A LOT FROM THIS
INDICTMENT EVEN THOUGH IT'S
SEVEN COUNTS.
>> THE PASSAGE THAT YOU READ AND
REFER TO ABOUT JULY 22ND 2016 IS
VERY IMPORTANT, ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS IS AFTER
WIKILEAKS IS PUBLISHED WE FIND
OUT THAT WIKILEAKS OR THE
RUSSIANS HAVE HACKED THE DNC
WIKILEAKS, IT CLOSES ITS STUFF
AND AFTER IT HAPPENS, SOMEONE IN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN SAYS TO STONE
WHAT GOES ON.
THAT SUGGESTS THERE WAS NO
KNOWLEDGE BEFORE HAND AND IT
DOES NOT SUPPORT ANY IDEA THAT
THERE WAS SOME SORT OF COLLUSION
SCHEME OR CONSPIRACY GOING ON.
THE MAIN THING TO REMEMBER
READING THIS INDICTMENT IS ROGER
STONE HAS ALWAYS BEEN KIND OF A
B.S. ARTIST, HE BRAGS ABOUT ALL
SORTS OF DIRTY DEEDS SOME OF
WHICH HE HASN'T EVEN DONE AND HE
WAS DOING THAT IN CONNECTION TO
THIS CASE IN PUBLIC AND THE
HOUSE HAD HIM COME FOR AN
INTERVIEW AND ASK HIM ABOUT
THOSE STATEMENTS UNDER OATH AND
HE ALLEGEDLY LIED ABOUT IT ALL.
IT HAS CAUGHT UP WITH HIM.
AS FAR AS REVEALING SOME KIND OF
SCHEME OR CONSPIRACY, IT JUST
DOESN'T DO IT.
>> Bret: LISTENED VERY QUICKLY
TO A QUESTION OF WHETHER ROGER
STONE WOULD FLIP AND SOMEHOW
TESTIFY AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
>> THERE IS NO CIRCUMSTANCE
WHATSOEVER UNDER WHICH I WILL
BEAR FALSE WITNESS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
>> WHEN YOU'RE FACING A LONG
PRISON TERM, THE MOST LOYAL OF
PEOPLE TURN TO THEMSELVES AND
SAY "I HAVE TO LOOK OUT FOR
MYSELF FIRST."
>> YOU GET TEN YEARS IN JAIL BUT
IF YOU MAKE UP STORIES, IT'S
CALLED FLIPPING AND IT ALMOST
OUGHT TO BE ILLEGAL.
>> Bret: IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
HE IS GOING TO DO THAT BUT WE'LL
HEAR ON TUCKER'S SHOW AT
8:00 P.M. TONIGHT.
>> I WOULD SAY THE WAY IN WHICH
THE FBI APPREHENDED HIM IN THAT
6:00 A.M. RAID INVOLVING SO MANY
AGENTS WITH WEAPONS, PERJURY OR
WITNESS TAMPERING IN TERMS OF A
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION I
THINK IT SHOWS THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL TRYING TO RATCHET UP THE
PRESSURE WHICH WILL CONTINUE AS
THIS LEGAL PROCESS MOVES ON.
AS YOU MENTIONED BEFORE, THESE